there's no excuse for not talking to the
world it just doesn't have to be your
thoughts and words every time my friends
the key to content success is you've got
to start documenting instead of creating
let me tell you how guys I know I look
like a fraud
scholars right now very high in the air
back from London
headed to our New York City Expressway a
video so many of you are stuck I can't
start I broke it down into that what how
and where right whw right like what are
you going to talk about but the way all
of you need to do this and how you
actually start is by doing you haven't
done anything yet
you know this whole fake it till you
make it brings no value to anybody you
need to make something and that thing is
a manifesto it's always been obvious
it's always been obvious what causes
success what I needed to do you know
every time I watch content the internet
what television
watched over the other night was
watching I was working she was
interviewing George Lucas and he was
saying the same [ __ ] we took it to all
the studios every single one of them and
nobody wanted it so what she did so I
said well I'm not going to give up now
you're stuck you haven't starting cuz
you're stuck I think the fear of losing
Trump's the excitement of victory for so
many people so here you go what what are
you going to talk about what do you want
to be known for look yourself in the
mirror and ask yourself what do I want
to do every day for the rest of my life
do that and see what people need to
understand is the way we communicate
today is so different and the platforms
have been redefined you want to be in
health and fitness you want to be in
strategy you wanna be in social media
you want to be in sneakers you want to
be in coffee you want to be in
electronics you want to be in in fashion
you like Smurfs Smurfs it up you can
make seventy thousand dollars a year
talking about the smoke whether that's
your mission or where you're at right
now
your truth manifesto
tell me what you're thinking about it
like if somebody made a video eight
years ago that I think fashion should be
high low I think people should wear
expensive stuff and inexpensive stuff in
one wardrobe they would have been like
the queen or king of the vision of the
fashion industry just by making a video
for the thing that Facebook why your
Instagram it's like Facebook's going to
buy into the grid four months later it
happens so I was on Piers Morgan this
companies 550 days old how the hell is
it worth a billion dollars and my
opening line is they stole it and then I
guess last year this time right Facebook
bought whatsapp for 18 billion and every
article like the next day after the news
came out is like oh wait a minute they
[ __ ] stole Instagram so how is
there's only certain few ways to
communicate in the world whether this is
video form something extreme yeah like
just get on a train and go away for a
week or something different you have to
break pattern whether this is audio form
sitting here listening to my music list
and I'm starting to find a little
clarity audio being a podcast you're an
outspoken advocate for both hustle them
self-awareness yeah so if you had to put
them in order even if it's a 1 a and 1
self awareness self awareness not even
for a little when you know who yes when
you know who you are
hustle sexier yeah like it would've been
cooler for like the people listening for
me to say hustle because it's cooler
right heck you name of do podcast put
the record on your phone and just speak
your truth as I sit here right now
writing this article or at least memo in
it because that's how I do it
get in front of a camera the southeast
out you know I'm old now kids so at 40
I've observed a lot I can tell you that
optimism and positivity is a huge
variable the
running into the grant me Gary instead
of a motivational quote or some sort of
collection just want to self-cam defeat
all your attention
set it up on the tripod or have a be
rocked your nephew or sister may give me
this give us real quick we can in turn
is here some of you guys might remember
him or you write it but the way all of
you need to do this and how you actually
start is by doing I create an obnoxious
amount of content because you're the
strategy of how we do it
don't do anything just keep watching
keep watching my stuff keep being
entertained by my energy keep being
inspired don't do don't [ __ ] have
dinner at seven o'clock and drink two
beers like when your strategy is right
you win and so we have figured out that
pillar content creates content
underneath it at scale everybody welcome
to the first hashtag askgaryvee I think
it's the first one but I actually do
think I tried to do this once before I
feel like I've got the team now in place
to actually do this more often
macro patience macro patience the my
patience you've got to deploy patience
you've got to love the process what's
the ROI of social media so I look at her
ago what's the ROI of your mother
there are so many people in here that
shouldn't be producing video because
that is not the best way they
communicate only a decade ago if I was
speaking here all I would be talking
about is blogging yet there are people
in this room that are caught up by
picture and video communication and they
are tremendous writers and they don't
realize that blogging or posting on
medium or even my favorite little hack
right now if you're a good writer and
you want to build up a profile for your
business or for yourself
I actually highly recommend you start
blogging inside of Facebook and
Instagram I literally mean writing seven
fifteen twenty five sentences three four
five paragraphs were a written content
within your feeds that people will
absolutely consume so that's number one
and to the what and and how right like
how are you going to do it and then
where distribution that's
that's what you need to figure out next
it's the hardest part for a lot of you
hardest part is to start the next
hardest remember things are hard harder
start hard to know what format to do it
in audio written video and then number
three how to get people to see it all go
down in the DM which key is providing
other people more value I just don't see
people doing it it blows me away and it
is absolutely wonderful and it is
absolutely going down on Instagram DM
influencers or you pay for it even pay
in facebook ads Instagram add bonds or
ship deals YouTube pre-rolls against
people of those interests fashion you
know food wine sneakers technology or or
you reach out to people that have
audiences search hashtags click them
look at the account then see how you can
bring them value DM them go in soft
bring value rinse and repeat two three
or five thousand times so the thing
maybe should do is go Upper East Side
you can get this guy looks like it's a
picture [ __ ] Instagram influencers right
now today for doers is the probably but
only behind Facebook ads the single best
arbitrage in marketing and then you try
and then you learn when you're a pioneer
you have to taste it there's no report
there's no white paper
there's no modeling mixed metrics that
are going to teach you how that's going
to work when you're the first explorer
you have to taste the berries and
hopefully they're not poisonous we're
living through this incredible era of
massive opportunity yet everybody's
talking and reading and nobody's [ __ ]
doing
start [ __ ] executing so what does
that mean that means you should write a
medium blog post every week content
podcast video written quotes pictures
and then tactics what scares me quite a
bit
that most of you where you see these
logos you think of a piece of content
that you make and you think of those
five channels and more as places where
you distribute it Twitter and Facebook
are tools Twitter and Facebook are
markers and crayons right your fax
machine these are not just distribution
channels these are channels where you
have to natively story tell Facebook
Twitter YouTube and Instagram or ABC NBC
and CBS and when I figured out for the
last decade is how to make mash and the
in Griffin Show and ER in size oh and my
question is how do i hustle and stop
being a [ __ ] no time i want to be where
you are
got what locking you some i don't know
other people's POV go on and see classic
style would get their meals yes please
take a step back and think about how
awesome it actually did it is imperative
that not only do you start thinking
about your content strategy on these
platforms for your business facebook
targeting I mean like I mean it's a like
you can literally put your business
address run a mail a radius around it or
everybody in the 708 one zip code or 208
802 as very Jersey in the house zip code
and everybody will see it and that's in
that zip code in that feed it's a piece
of cake so if you talk about coffee
Google the word coffee and the word blog
or coffee and media company and
literally email every editor and writer
of every coffee blog on the internet the
way you're gonna make money online and
by the way anywhere it's by grabbing it
so if I were you I would do this I would
go to Google I would type in beer so I
would click this one pop glasses calm I
go to this site I see what they have I
would find that the phone number of this
place here's a phone number I pick it up
I will who I speak to about you guys
possibly advertising a light beer blog
that's mean then search the hashtag
coffee and go to every coffee influencer
and coffee barista
Coffee Mediasite on Instagram and B mmm
and ask them to give awareness to this
manifesto you just wrote and one out of
347 well but that's better than
undervaluing just that one view needs to
be the right view but it's one view is a
humongous mistake sent until you do it
and one that I will just sit here right
now and make this video hoping that one
[ __ ]
one doctor says oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] it
where the written word we look at the
medium blinked in the word presses you
start a blog right or you do it on your
Facebook or you do in your internet how
there's only really three core waves in
the current internet to really
communicate to the world the written
word or video what I'm doing right now
YouTube Facebook video Instagram
one-minute version video is the other
way we communicate a number three audio
the boom of podcast these are the things
that matter what the [ __ ] do you want to
talk about how are you going to
communicate it written audio or video
and how do you get people access see
them this is where we showed you how to
go into the DM right then before you've
got to figure out how to use some money
and use Facebook ads and target the
people that you're trying to reach or
grinding hustle just a little emailing
700 to 1500 different blogs or media
sites and saying if you want to
distribute my content somebody has a 14
thousand person email newsletter about
coffee news find that person and ask
them just gotta ask and be smart drive
jab right hook ask them what you can do
for them because you want everybody to
read them eat posted on medium and hit
up the editors of medium who curate
content post a link on it and still read
it right hit up the 4700 coffee
influencers on YouTube and send them a
message and ask them if they want to
read it on their YouTube channel that
has 147 views 147 news is better than 0
the [ __ ] work that's how you start
[Music]
Oh